aber nicht ganz nackig hatte gail
asterix helm auf und asterix schwer
ich bin bald jetzt nur noch oder hey
leute herzlich willkommen zur zweiten
folge verbessert das sagt ja immer noch
die serie wo wir uns geschichten erzähle
und die anderen beiden müssen dann immer
sagen ob die story war ist oder falsch
ist wenn ihr das ganze erklärt haben
wollte erste folge gab es auf einem
kanal und auf dem kanal von gebrochenen
daumen ok brocken ist die bi und das
geheimnisvolle geräusche
was ist da könnt ihr euch daran erinnern
was ist dieses geräusch wie gut wäre
unser wald überlegt und zwar mit dem
toni was mega gomis der erste bekommt
immer einen diamanten der zweite bekommt
ein eisenbahner entkoppeln und da er
erst er war hier der manuel hat er einen
diamanten bekommen
der kandidat anreisen bekommen und der
marke werden und wir machen diesmal nur
zwei stories weil das erste war 25
minuten lang
deswegen vielleicht wenn wir nachher
ganz ganz viele stories haben dann mach
mal und wieder mehr aber müssen wir
gucken ja wir sind gerade mal ein waren
hoch gehen oder kommentare was wir
sicher grad an vorproduzieren weil
konkrete urlaub fährt deswegen deswegen
kann man das objekt noch gleich ankommen
und bekommt noch nicht auf ausdruck
kommt genau das kommt dann so ihr fehlt
übrigens die tür
okay es geht los
manuel bei mir wieder ist dadurch sind
jetzt zwei stories die eine harmlos die
anderen dafür extrem gut
das anders es war so klein da war ich so
war ich dann mal schweiß nicht so 6
die sieben nein nein so 99 schon eher 9
11 12 10
da war ich manchmal zu faul das
treppenhaus runterzugehen
ich wurde der ersten etage damit dass er
ist also ich bin dann über die brüstung
so geklettert hab mich dann so
festgehalten an der und war rückwärts
runter gesamt immer ich zu faul war sind
schon noch 5 meter vielleicht hat nein
wenn du drei unter hengst mit den händen
mit den füßen sehr viel einer zwei meter
das ist sich wie überlebt man auf jeden
fall aber ich bin mir nicht sicher wie
kann so voll sein und aus dem ersten
stock das sind vielleicht zentren
verdammte scheiße das ist eine lüge die
kann zwar sein
das ist die moral von der geschicht mit
dem springen noch mehr zeit einfach sich
daran zu halten führt zu ziehen dann
reagiert also bei mir die story wir
waren damals nicht beim kurz treffen ein
ich war ich war 15 ja gut ist
zweieinhalb jahre alt ca na gut ich
hatte gerade mein iphone bekommen iphone
3gs war das damals so mit vertrag und
man sich das dann so vor zwei jahren
kommt man sie war das dann da kommt man
sich das schon mal so leisten so und ich
drei tage nach dem geburtstag dann bei
meinem geburtstag nachher noch beim
freund übernachtet er sich bei ihm der
täter am kleinen see schwimmen teich im
garten und ich da dann natürlich gern
fußball gespielt und ich war werten
sonnentor abgesteckt mit somit zur
polizei wie man das damals gemacht hatte
und das haben wir logischerweise direkt
hinter vor dem teich gemacht warum weiß
ich nicht wie man jungen dumm und
behindert vom balkon herunter gesprungen
wir spielen und der ball der ball fliegt
air fliegt und ich springe undicht cola
in diesem teich rein und wenn man kohl
hat dann kann man sich da nicht so lange
leicht aufrappeln wenn man dann so ana
schlaegel ist und ich falle in diesem
teich rhein mit handy und alle zusammen
mit geld und alles und erstmal
personalausweis kaputt war der kaputte
fest gar nicht also ich brauche auf
jeden fall neuen weil ja irgendwie was
unter dieser folie war und alles möglich
auf jeden fall im iphone auch direkt im
eimer
dann muss ich wieder mein altes handy
werden einfach so als strafe von meinen
eltern aber die haben doch zwei monate
später wieder an iphone dann so halbwegs
was dazu getan und das ist eine lüge
das war so klar und sparst du bist echt
sind
du bist du in jork gelernt sein verliert
der braunen sie dumm sein und zwei mal
sein iphone kaputt machen
naja ich meine ja doch wenigstens nicht
kaputt gemacht als er vom balkon dann
wärs gewesen
vom balkon runter mit seite oder handy
auf den boden gedrückt als ich noch jung
und hübsch war wenig durch den garten
gelaufen aber nicht ganz nackig
denn ich hatte so ein geiler strings
helm auf und asterix schwer wieder
videos familienfest
du bist meine kleine gewesen der rat
könnte dann schnee gesehen also da du da
so viele details reingebracht da sind
auch gesagt hast ja ich war der
familienfest ich hab so viele fotos
davon würde ich erst mal sagen weil das
so heftig dass das eine lüge ist
die meisten wollen dass das war's aber
ich auch das ist die lüge aber ich
glaube du denkst du wie ich denke
deswegen ist doch war da warten im
moment noch nicht gucken
ich muss noch überlegen hast du ein
ich sag mal das ist was ich sagen dass
flüge genommen alter schickt mir bitte
einfach video in den wenigsten springt
dann nicht vom balkon
er bewegt sich wenigstens habe ich jetzt
zwei punkte
die mimik lesen meine beine brachten
ich bin so ein bus gefahren bus gefahren
in der 8 da kennt sie keiner mehr den 4
bei den alten noch im vierer drin aber
im rücken zur fahrtrichtung also das
heißt ich konnte mir die leute die da
saßen so angucken erlebten 3 und sohn
hat einer auf einmal einen tipp bekommen
ich weiß nicht was wichtig für jungen
kaputt wanne
er steht auf der wanne letzten reihe
steht auf
eine anzeige bekommen wegen sexueller
belästigung wartet er war aber auch so
ein bisschen
nein ich glaube dir das nicht klappt es
ein nein ich glaube nicht dass ich sage
es war alter was glaube ich dir nicht
schwer planig seien schwer auf den lieb
ich schwöre auf das was passiert ist ich
will auf meine beiden eier dass sie
sofort aus meiner hose gehen sollen wenn
das nicht passiert ist
junge trenkmann bist du dir sicher dass
das nicht geträumt hat ja gut an meine
zweite story ich schreibe mein kumpel
bei facebook und ich mich dann auf
einmal so ein spaß so eingefallen weil
die y taste wenn meiner tastatur die ist
halt nicht da also ich kann halt noch
drauf drücken aber die taste derzeit
nicht mehr da also war damals an einem
laptop
jedenfalls habe ich hart und ich hab
einfach geschrieben du ich hab kein y
mehr und ich hab das y sogar in den sat
1 geschrieben
kannst du mir mal deinen senden
und er schickt mir eiskalt substanz ohne
hier kopiert dass ich so jung danke mein
zeh funktioniert auch nicht mehr
schreibt mir mal an c und er schreibt
mir eiskalt auch noch einen zeh obwohl
im schreiben c drin ist und ich glaube
das c geschrieben und ich so jo danke
und das war's okay habt ihr das was so
passiert ist dass ich zu alt um freunde
aber dann greift ihr lassen ich sage
dass der wahrheit priester mit der mini
in fluss von den simsen
also war ich weiß wenn ich eine
läppische stoppen story nehmen dachte
ich würde denken bestimmt was war das
okay
wenigstens bist du nicht vom balkon
gesprungen oder was ich im anflug
schwert und mit einem händchen denn bald
jetzt nur noch hass oder der schnitt
also begab sich zu einer zeit als meine
vor zwei jahren oder so weil meine
eltern im urlaub endlich für eine woche
oder zehn tage oder so die lassen so ein
bisschen geld hierfür essen und so hält
es nicht für essen ausgegeben ja ich hab
mal sache nicht
kino und da habe ich mir eine festplatte
gekauft damals weil die terabyte oder so
war auf jeden fall zu der zeit noch
relativ viel und wir haben kein
klopapier mehr da und ich hatte auch
kein geld mehr neues zu kaufen und war
dann auch ein bisschen geizig und das
hat dazu geführt dass ich einfach immer
wenn ich geschichten hab einfach danach
balkon gesprungen
das war
alter [ __ ] mann
ich habe fünf die kann das alter der
könig cobblestone malte wir beide sind
die schlechtesten der weinhändler wenn
wir sind schon echt richtig mies aber
wenigstens seid ihr nicht vom balkon
gesprungen
das macht es wenn euch die story von
pfeilen haben beziehungsweise diese
folge gefallen hat ist erst mal einen
daumen hoch geben oder halt immer noch
wenn ihr irgendwas witz so wie wir die
serie noch besser machen können und
einfach einen kommentar schreiben
per mail an die e mail die wir in der
ersten folge eigene band haben sich
jedoch in der beschreibung und wir
blenden die hier jetzt noch mal ein da
oben also ich zumindest meine und
nächste folge kommt nächsten montag bei
den beiden banausen hierbei manal ritter
oder beim bummel wir euch das genannt
oder beim balkon zu balkon jump bei den
rhein auf dem kanal kommt die folge
treffen und ihr habt ihr noch was zu
sagen das was der haut allein unter de
bis demnächst